إطلاق نار من خلال بورت أو برنس
بعد اغتيال الرئيس ،
وبعد 36 ساعة فقط من قيام مجموعة من أكثر
من عشرين كولومبيًا واثنين من
الأمريكيين الهايتيين بقتل
الرئيس ،
إما أن يتم اعتقاله أو
الإعلان عن وفاته.
مصدر مطلع
على العملية
لتعقبهم ، انتشر مقطع فيديو ليلي من وقت
وفاة الرئيس بسرعة كبيرة
حيث يمكنك سماع أحد المشتبه بهم يدعي أن
هناك عملية تعطيل جارية في وقت لاحق
يمكن رؤية قافلة مؤلفة من خمس سيارات
تغادر المنطقة بسهولة
ولكن على الطريق ، تم نصب فخ
بينما كانت القافلة تسير في طريق kenskoff
، كان هناك حاجز على الطريق جاهزًا
لن تسمح لهم قوات الأمن المدججة بالسلاح
بالمرور دون وصول قتال
ورؤية أنهم لا يستطيعون المضي
قدمًا حيث تتوقف القافلة في
جزء منها يمكنك  انظر هنا
يقول مصدرنا إن المشتبه بهم
قفزوا ورأوا هذا المبنى عبر الطريق
وهم يتسابقون نحوه على
الفور ويأخذون الدرج إلى
الشارع  econd
floor في هذا المبنى
سيبدأ هؤلاء المرتزقة المزعومون في الدفاع عن
أنفسهم
ولكن في نفس اللحظة يأتون إلى
هنا وفقًا
لمصدرنا ، تتخذ قوات الأمن الهايتية
قرارًا حاسمًا
يعرفون أن هؤلاء المهاجمين المزعومين
لديهم ذخيرة محدودة للطعام
والمياه ولا  لذلك قرروا
بشكل أساسي انتظارهم بعد حوالي 12 ساعة بعد
الخبز في 90 درجة بالإضافة إلى قيام سلطات الحرارة الهايتية
بإلقاء الغاز المسيل للدموع
أمام المبنى ، وهو ما يكفي لفرض
المفاوضات ، وفي النهاية أرسل الكولومبيون بالداخل
أربعة أشخاص
بما في ذلك هذا الرجل
واحد من اثنين  الأمريكيون الهايتيون
الذين احتجزتهم السلطات
، انضم إليهم الأمريكي الهايتي الآخر ورهينتان من هايتي
،
وزوج من ضباط الشرطة كانوا في
منزل الرئيس
وفقًا لمصدرنا في مرحلة ما
أثناء المفاوضات ،
لا يزال هناك مجموعة من الكولومبيين يخرجون من هذا
المبنى.
وابدأ في التوجه لأعلى هذا التل على
الجانب الخلفي من المبنى
وفي النهاية  لي أنهم يشقون طريقهم إلى وجهة
تبدو
غريبة على بعد حوالي 100
متر فوق التل من المبنى ، حيث
تقع سفارة تايوان التي
يعتقد مصدرنا أن الكولومبيين ذهبوا إلى هناك
لأنه لم يكن مكانًا سهلاً لدخول الشرطة
نظرًا لحصانتهم الدبلوماسية
من أجل  الوصول إلى
السفارة على الرغم من أنهم اضطروا إلى السير
في حي سكني جميل
ووفقًا
لمصدرنا ، أبلغ شخص ما السلطات بأن هذه
المجموعة من الرجال المدججين بالسلاح
كانت هنا عندما وصلوا إلى
السفارة وجدوا مبنىً فارغًا إلى حد كبير
باستثناء  قام اثنان من حراس الأمن
الذين قيدوا قوات الأمن
بتطويق السفارة على وجه السرعة ثم حولوا
انتباههم مرة أخرى إلى المبنى أدناه
حيث اعتقدوا أن بعض المشتبه بهم ما
زالوا
، فقد حان الوقت للذهاب
في فريق مهاجم صغير إلى
الطابق الأرضي وتم استقبالهم.
حريق شرس يمكنك سماعه
من حفنة من الكولومبيين الذين كانوا
لا يزالون
داخل حريق لمدة ساعة محطمة
النوافذ المحطمة
أسقف وجدران خرسانية وفي
النهاية تقول الحكومة إن ثلاثة كولومبيين على الأقل
لقوا حتفهم في القتال
في اليوم التالي بإذن من تايوان
ذهبت السلطات إلى السفارة
ويقول مصدرنا إن السلطات فحصت كاميرات الدوائر التلفزيونية المغلقة
ووجدت ما يقرب من عشرة كولومبيين في
غرفة انتهى بهم الأمر بالتخلي  حتى
دون مزيد من القتال لم يتم العثور على ما يقرب من نصف
دزينة